-♪ Cause I, I,
I'm in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
-♪ Shoes on,
get up in the morn' ♪
♪ Cup of milk,
let's rock and roll ♪
♪ King Kong, kick the drum ♪
♪ Rolling on like
a Rolling Stone ♪
♪ Sing song
when I'm walking home ♪
♪ Jump up to the top, LeBron ♪
♪ Ding-dong,
call me on my phone ♪
♪ Ice tea
and a game of ping pong ♪
-♪ This is getting heavy,
can you hear the bass boom? ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
-♪ Woo-hoo ♪
-♪ Life is sweet as honey,
yeah ♪
♪ This beat cha-ching
like money ♪
-♪ Disco overload,
I'm into that ♪
♪ I'm good to go ♪
♪ I'm diamond,
you know I glow up ♪
-♪ Hey, so let's go ♪
-♪ 'Cause I, I,
I'm in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
-♪ Hey! ♪
-♪ Shining through the city ♪
♪ With a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite,
whoa-oh-oh ♪
-♪ Bring a friend,
join the crowd ♪
♪ Whoever wanna come along ♪
♪ Word up, talk the talk, just
move like we off the wall ♪
♪ Day or night,
the sky's alight ♪
♪ So we dance to
the break of dawn ♪
-♪ Ladies and gentlemen,
I got the medicine ♪
♪ So you should keep ya eyes
on the ball ♪
-♪ This is getting heavy
can you hear the bass boom? ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
-♪ Woo-hoo ♪
-♪ Life is sweet as honey,
yeah ♪
-♪ This beat cha-ching
like money ♪
-♪ Disco overload,
I'm into that ♪
♪ I'm good to go ♪
♪ I'm diamond,
you know I glow up ♪
-♪ Hey, so let's go ♪
-♪ 'Cause I, I,
I'm in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
-♪ Hey! ♪
-♪ Shining through the city ♪
♪ With a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite,
whoa-oh-oh ♪
♪ Dyn-na-na-na, na-na-na-na-na,
na-na-na ♪
-♪ Life is dynamite ♪
-♪ Dyn-na-na-na, na-na-na-na-na,
na-na-na ♪
[ Beat-boxing ]
♪ Shining through the city
with a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite,
whoa-oh-oh ♪
-♪ Cause I, I,
I'm in the stars tonight ♪
♪ So watch me bring the fire
and set the night alight ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Shining through the city ♪
♪ With a little funk and soul ♪
♪ Light it up like dynamite,
whoa-oh-oh ♪